The battle against Thanos is nearing its end.
If you're a Marvel fan, you already know the
god of thunder is important, but here's a
look at some of the biggest reasons Thor will
be even more important in Avengers 4 than
you might already think.
It's personal
Thor has really been through the ringer lately
between Thor: Ragnarok and Avengers: Infinity
War.
After losing his father in Thor: Ragnarok,
he had to watch his brother be strangled to
death by Thanos right in front of his face
while he watched helplessly.
And that was after watching his best friend
Heimdall get stabbed by Thanos too.
Thor doesn't really have anyone left at this
point.
"Your sister and your dad?"
"Both dead."
"But still got a mom, though?"
"Killed by a dark elf."
"Best friend?"
"Stabbed through the heart."
It's not the kind of thing you can just shake
off.
You can bet Thor will remember that come Avengers
4.
"I'm not sad, you idiot.
I'm pissed off!"
"Ohhh."
"Angry!"
It's political
While Thor is clearly being eaten up by the
loss of his brother and friend, the other
glaring emotional factor at play here is his
role as the king of Asgard.
Of course, the physical kingdom of Asgard
doesn't exist since Surtur destroyed it at
the end of Ragnarok.
But the people of Asgard were still alive
and well, led by their fearless king and headed
for a new home, Earth, until they ran into
Thanos' ship and were partly slaughtered in
the process.
Since Odin passed, Thor has had a pretty rough
go of it as King of Asgard.
With the last of his people scattered and
homeless, adrift in space, Avengers 4 will
serve as the perfect chance for their king
to rise up.
It's professional
While most of the Avengers found their way
into the superhero game, Thor was born into
it.
He's been a hero and champion for thousands
of years and one of the original Avengers.
When the dust settled at the end of Infinity
War, there were five very important characters
left: Iron Man, Captain America, Thor, Hulk,
and Black Widow.
They're the original Avengers, and in Avengers
4, they're headed for an epic showdown with
Thanos.
You can bet Thor will show up for work, and
not just as an angry god consumed with rage,
but as a part of a well-oiled Avengers team.
Frequent flyer
Thor is an intergalactic traveler who's very
comfortable with the perils of traveling through
space.
This makes him a crucial element even in the
struggle to reach Thanos in the first place.
It looks like Thanos is not on Earth as the
movie ends, and after that dreaded finger
snap, there just aren't that many intergalactic
superheroes left.
Iron Man and Nebula are stranded on Titan,
and they'll likely need some space travel
in order to reconnect with everyone else.
Rocket is still alive and an experienced pilot
to boot, but he didn't bring his spaceship
to Earth.
Thor's role as a flying god who can summon
the Bifrost will definitely come in handy.
Thor and Hulk: Besties
Thor and Hulk have been matched up throughout
the MCU saga in an endlessly entertaining,
rough and tumble relationship all along.
From smashing around a giant aircraft in the
first Avengers movie to dueling in front of
a massive crowd gladiator style in Thor: Ragnarok,
the two Avengers are two of a kind.
"We're the same, you and I.
We're just a couple of hot-headed fools."
"Yeah, same.
Hulk like fire, Thor like water."
But when push comes to shove, these two brawny
characters always come together to provide
some serious muscle to the Avengers team.
With Hulk clearly shaping up to be an important
part of Avengers 4, there's no doubt that
Thor will be right there next to his friend
on the front lines.
Trading up to Stormbreaker?
We all loved Thor's hammer-wielding in the
past, and saying farewell to Mjolnir in Thor:
Ragnarok was a sad moment.
"Sounds like you had a pretty special and
intimate relationship with this hammer and
that losing it was almost comparable to losing
a loved one."
"It's a nice way of putting it."
But the truth is that there's just as much
possibility in Thor's new weapon, if not more.
When Thor arrived at the battle of Wakanda,
he used Stormbreaker to cut right through
the Infinity Gauntlet's power, showing that
his new axe was for more than chopping firewood.
But we only got to see it in action in the
last few minutes of the movie, and Marvel
has proven over the years that they generally
don't build up huge plot momentum only to
fritter it away in a few moments.
Stormbreaker aside, the hand wielding the
weapon has become even stronger.
In a one on one fight, no one else can seem
to get a step up on Thanos, not even the Hulk.
However, Thor actually managed to nearly kill
Thanos.
His only mistake?
"You should've gone for the head."
Thor's story arc
Finally, we have Thor's story arc.
While the god has been an established presence
in the MCU since he flew into theaters in
2011, we're really dealing with a whole new
character since Thor: Ragnarok.
Before Ragnarok, Thor was little more than
a support character.
After it, he became the bona fide king of
Asgard, and truly a top-tier character in
the MCU.
With the third Avengers movie now on the books
and Avengers 4 heading toward its May 2019
release date, we can only wait and see how
Thor's character arc ends up.
"I'm not as strong as you."
"No.
You're stronger."